Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di Cucina Buttata, adesso noi
italiani sappiamo che a livello
culinario condividiamo il podio
dell'eccellenza con pochissimi altri
paesi a livello proprio di materia prima
e ricette in generale piatti e
tradizione però allo stesso tempo da
grandi poteri derivano grandi responsabilità. Questo vuol dire che il
più delle volte, quando qualcuno non si
comporta bene in cucina, noi siamo i
primi a tanarlo e i primi soprattutto a
creare un bell'insieme di odio nei
confronti del prossimo. Un povero
francese ha creato un po' di tempo fa un
video nel quale faceva vedere come
faceva la carbonara
ora questo tizio è stato forse uno dei
più odiati del 2017 credo ed è così che
mi sono detto un secondo odio le persone
che criticano senza sapere,  una cosa
interessante sarebbe stata quella di
provare questa ricetta e vedere se
effettivamente, da romano, è approvata
oppure no. Scusate se sorrido ma ho un
po' di paura per la mia salute e per la
mia incolumità
Che dire, partiamo. Ci sono un sacco di
persone che seguono i tutorial di altre
persone... Oggi noi seguiamo il tutorial
di una pippa in cucina, forse peggio
ancora di me. Per fare questa carbonara
oscena servono: Scarse doti culinarie
farfalle, il tipico taglio di pasta per
la carbonara
perché si sa le farfalle muoiono in un
giorno ed è quello che più o meno è
successo a tutte le persone che hanno
testato questa ricetta a casa loro...
In teoria andrebbe la pancetta ma noi non
ce l'abbiamo fatta quindi abbiamo
comunque preso di guanciale stick perché non si poteva, uovo, fermo lì, pecorino
anche se in realtà lui mentre il
parmigiano però non ce la facevamo delle
cipolle, pepe
cos'è questo... Prezzemolo che si sa anche essere un potente veleno se ingerito
in quantità abbondanti, il che vuol dire che a fine pasto potremmo comunque decidere di
finircelo tutto quanto a crudo e LEI...
Pesa più di una pistola in mano in
questo momento, la panna da cucina... Perché, cioè in Francia avete una cucina
buonissima ma perché fare la carbonara... Fate l'escargot, les fondue cioè quelle
cose, quei termini francesi... Les quiche,
les saint lorraine, il montblanc, No...
A carbonara.
Vediamo un pochino che cosa ha fatto
Farfalle...
Ok... Dobbiamo tagliare una cipolla che poi la
cipolla, nella carbonara, non ci va però mi
sembra il minimo perché in realtà io conosco
un ragazzo che ci mette la cipolla e la
sua carbonara è molto buona. Anche qualche chef stellato... Mettete la
cipolla? Eh ma io dubito che stiamo seguendo uno chef stellato lo sai? Che tecnica è?
Sono un po' confuso... Che poi lui la taglia
così, non la taglia a pezzetti
Ok, va bene, io seguo quello che vedo. A
questo punto lui prende la cipolla e la
mette in un lato della pentola, così.
Prendiamo il guanciale... I cani hanno iniziato ad abbaiare eh. Si, hanno iniziato
a abbaiare "Non farlo, non farlo! NON FARLO!" Prende il guanciale e lo mette sempre in un lato
Di lato... Che poi in realtà non prende il
guanciale, prende la pancetta
Aspetta, ho bisogno di un momento... Cioè lui, lui... Guarda gli
ingredienti stanno cercando di scappare.
Lui prende le farfalle e le mette crude in
un angolo... Era più difficile di quanto non
pensassi. Andiamo avanti. Acqua, acqua! 15 minuti a
fuoco dolce? Cosa esce da qua dentro
a fine cottura! Ragazzi èp èsp cioè sto ehm capito? Io me
ne sto già lavando le mani di questa
cosa, non è la ricetta mia. Mettiamo un po'
di acqua dentro... Mamma mia. Mamma mia che porcata. Facciamo andare a 15 minuti a fuoco dolce
Potete prendere a questo punto un mestolo o anche una scopa usata
per mettere giù la pasta perché non
credo che a questo punto importi
Si incolla, succede qualcosa di strano là dentro, ma poi tu dovrai girare un po'. No lui non gira niente, la prende e
la mette direttamente dai fornelli sul pavimento, capito? Vicino alla ciotola del cane...
Pensavo  che sarebbe stato divertente vedere come gli stranieri interpretano i piatti
italiani, sembra di stare all'interno di
un film horror in questo momento cioè io
penso che adesso mi chiamerà qualcuno e mi dirà "Sette giorni..." Anzi "Sette chili!"
Ogni volta che in Francia succede questo, in Italia una
massaia schioda ,come le fatine di Peter
Pan... Sta facendo schiuma
Mamma mia. Hai presente? Quello è tipo il
grasso... Ah ecco cos'è. Cosa ho fatto,
perdonatemi, io chiedo scusa. In questo
momento aggiungere la panna mi sembra, non lo so, una mossa valida, da Cracco.
Sta bollendo... Sta bollendo e quindi adesso dovrebbe bollire per... Ah per tipo 10 minuti
così almeno viene bene al dente, nel
senso che prendi i denti e li butti
via perché vuoi masticarla con le gengive. Io sento quel timer che sembra quello di una bomba a orologeria
pronto a scoppiare e finirà il mondo
appena sentirò 'Pii' e quei due cosi si
baceranno. Si sta amalgamando da solo... Beh se si amalgama da solo vuol dire che c'è un pensiero dietro...
io spero se magni pure da solo. Buono!
Croccante il guanciale eh, bello stufato. Oh Dio
ragazzi qui ci sono delle patatine
fritte... Me le prendi? Ma non possiamo derubare
Pierfrancesco delle sue patatine fritte. Vabbè lo deliziamo però lasciandogli un bel piatto di pasta
Dai, sono delle patatine classiche...
Come la ricetta che stiamo facendo, classica...
Ma poi Enrico scusa ti rovini l'appetito...
Non esce fuori un cattivo odore da quella pentola... Però poi pensa che quella roba lì alla fine è una carbonara. Pensa se rimaniamo sconvolti dalla
dalla bontà... Dalla bontà. Dobbiamo essere obiettivi, per il momento quello che
abbiamo fatto è stato abominevole. Da qui vado in chiesa mi confesso e poi posso
proseguire la mia giornata.
Non bisogna prenderlo come un piatto di
pasta, è una materia utilizzata in maniera
diversa... Ah ok. Ma tipo legna per il camino?
Che magari è altamente infiammabile, la butti lì e fai cioè un barbecue pazzesco
È cambiato qualcosa? Sì, è cotta da 7 ore... Tre minuti e mezzo. In questo momento questo bollore, lo senti?
un interprete della natura direbbe "Perché ci stai facendo questo, perché?"
Stanno bestemmiando quei pezzi di
guanciale... comunque è uno scempio alla vista eh
Dai una mescolata per ingolosire
il pubblico. MMMMM!
Che bella! Ha una consistenza pari, secondo me, a quella del Bostik cioè se voi ora la lanciate
dalla finestra questa qui rimbalza
sull'asfalto e ti ritorna in bocca
Considera che sembra che rimbalzi il
cucchiaio quando lo immergi... No, no non riesco ad andare
più giù di così. Il fuoco deve essere più dolce. Però stai facendo il possibile per
alterare la ricetta posso dirlo? No, dovevamo metterci la pancetta infatti
non dovevamo mettere il guanciale, Dovevamo metterci il pecor... Il forma... il parmig... Il boh. Quella polvere che loro usano...
Una polvere al formaggio e non il pecorissimo. pecorino romano dop, stiamo barando...
OK!
Carbonara...Oddio mi stavo per infilzare da solo con le forbici, gli utensili di questa cucina stanno cercando di fermarmi
Giriamo... Sentitela... Parla francese. Scusa. Impiattiamo
Preparatevi. Perdonami, ti prego scusami. No non ce la posso fare...
Ma che c'entra adesso questo, cosa c'entra il prezzemolo adesso. Siete seduti
a casa?
se siete tipo in metro in questo momento
in qualche posto dove state in piedi
se siete magari in fila alle poste, sedetevi.
Oh Dio santo! Secondo voi ce ne ho messo
abbastanza da renderlo mortale o è di
per sé l'accoppiata degli ingredienti
che renderà mortale questa ricetta. Ed ecco la nostra 'CarboNOra'. Cos'è che dice qui?
Bon appétit... Ci aggiunge un altro
pochino di pepe
e chiude il video con "Bon Appétit", io l'avrei chiuso con "Bella M***a". Per il bene della scienza... Prendi tutto eh...
È l'unione tra uno spaghetto alle vongole,
n'ovo e questo stufato di cipolle il
guanciale sembra... Hai presente quando tiri fuori dai
brodi di carne il pezzo di carne stufato?
Stessa cosa solo che non è un brodo... Venite... Uno scenario aberrante...
Mi raccomando ragazzi prendete uovo, tutto. Bravo! Mammamia Gianmarco, mamma... Meno male che è caduto... Per fortuna...
Allora siete proh Dio santo! Stai perdendo tutto? No, no io mi rifiuto, prendi un bel boccone. Vai! Alla tua!
Vi odiate così tanto alla tua? Sentite lo
spaghetto alle vongole? Questa maionese... Ve?
Disgustosa... È terrificante, a me si
stringe il cuore che dall'altra
dall'altra parte dell'europa... Però te la mangi eh... Perché sto facendo un'analisi per
capire quanto mi si stringe il cuore per
il fatto che d'altra parte dell'europa
qualcuno consiglieri questa roba... Italia. Italia... Poi dici perché
siamo suscettibili no? Io vorrei fare un
appello. Tizio... Ma cioè che cosa avevi in
testa, a cosa stai pensando il giorno in
cui hai postato un video nel quale facevi
questo... Mi stanno chiamando... È la polizia ragazzi! Smonta tutto, smonta tutto! Presto!
Io vi chiedo scusa se chiudiamo questo
video con una nota amara con un retrogusto
amaro che è più o meno quello che
abbiamo noi in questo momento in bocca
però vorrei fare un appello a quella
persona e non ha mostrato il suo viso
se qualcuno anzi lo può tradurre in
francese qua sotto perché io non so
parlarlo. Ti prego smettila, tutti quei
carboidrati non meritano un trattamento
simile. No... (Colpo di tosse)
E con questo chiudo, hai fatto ammalare mio fratello. Alla prossima domenica con
una nuova ricetta e forse un pizzico di
allegria più. Che schifo!
Madre santa...